cuando mustafa le lanzó una pelota de
playa a su amigo la velocidad horizontal
de la pelota cambió mientras volaba en
el aire la relación entre el tiempo
transcurrido t en segundos desde que
mustafá lanzó la pelota y la velocidad
horizontal vdd en centímetros sobre
segundo se modelan con la siguiente
función y aquí tenemos la función
completa la siguiente oración sobre el
cambio porcentual de la velocidad
horizontal de la pelota cada segundo un
cierto porcentaje de la velocidad
horizontal se suma am o se resta de la
velocidad horizontal total de la pelota
ahora una cosa que es importante es
observar lo que dice aquí la velocidad
horizontal de la pelota cambio mientras
volaba en el aire y bueno si el tiempo
está en segundos y el tiempo va a
aumentar entonces este tiempo de aquí va
a aumentar y se aumenta es un exponente
de algo que es menor que 1 entonces dt
va a disminuir estás de acuerdo
esto no está diciendo que en definitiva
se resta de la velocidad horizontal
total de la pelota pero lo que también
queremos saber es cuánto estamos
restando y bueno para saber eso observa
lo siguiente cada vez que aumente el
tiempo en uno nuestra razón común o
nuestro factor de cambio va a ser 0.81
estás de acuerdo
hagamos una pequeña tabla para que sea
todo mucho más claro si pongo aquí mi
tabla y por aquí mi tabla y pongo de
este lado el tiempo y de este lado
vedete de este lado vedete
bueno pues observa lo que va a pasar
cuando el tiempo vale cero cuando el
tiempo vale cero voy a tener 44 que
multiplica a 0.81 esto elevado a la
potencia cero pero esto va a ser 1 por
lo tanto solamente me quedo con 4 esto
va a ser
de lujo y qué pasa cuando el tiempo vale
uno bueno para el tiempo vale 1 voy a
multiplicar a 4 por el factor de 0.81
esto elevado la primera potencia pero
bueno esto es exactamente lo mismo que
tener 4 que multiplica a 0.81 estás de
acuerdo por lo tanto me voy a quedar
solamente con el 81% de estos cuatro
centímetros sobre segundos que tenía de
velocidad inicial ahora qué va a pasar
cuando tenga dos segundos bueno cuando
tenga dos segundos me voy a quedar con
cuatro que multiplica a 0.81 esto
elevado al cuadrado que por cierto esto
es lo mismo que 4 que multiplica a 0.81
que subes multiplica a 0.81 es decir me
voy a quedar con el 81% de lo que tenía
antes y lo que tenía antes en el 81%
mi velocidad inicial que era 4 pero ojo
nos preguntan cada segundo qué
porcentaje de la velocidad horizontal se
resta de la velocidad horizontal total
de la pelota y aquí estaríamos muy
tentados a poner 81 % pero si estamos
restando el 81 por ciento de la
velocidad horizontal no nos quedaría 81
por ciento estás de acuerdo nos quedaría
muy poquito porcentaje y lo que nosotros
queremos es quedarnos con el 81 por
ciento entonces la pregunta sería
cuántos le estoy quitando a la velocidad
horizontal y bueno para eso habrá que
ver cuánto le falta de 81 por ciento
para llegar a ser el 100 por ciento y
bueno si te das cuenta si al cien por
ciento le quitamos un 81 por ciento que
es con lo que me voy a quedar bueno voy
a obtener un 19% por lo tanto cada
segundo le voy a quitar un 19% de la
velocidad de horizontal
a la velocidad horizontal total de la
pelota